after a week where sugray delivered
damning details on downing street
parties and the chancellor delivered 15
billion pounds for the cost of living
westminster is quiet in recess
but the letters keep coming today the
former attorney general jeremy wright
said that with regret he's concluded
that for the good of this and future
governments the prime minister should
resign hours later london mp eliot
coburn confirmed his letter of no
confidence saying that he is especially
appalled that the revelations of the
poor treatment of security and cleaning
staff at number 10. westminster mp nikki
aitkin said if she was the prime
minister she'd call for a vote of
confidence in herself we still seem to
be in denial and it's time it's time to
shake off this this partisan stockholm
syndrome i believe that our party brand
is suffering we will lose the next
election on current trajectory as
reflected in recent elections by local
elections and no doubt in the tough
by-elections ahead and when you get the
the church elders in the party such as
lord hague now expressing who's
concerned you know we need to listen
35 mps have publicly questioned the
prime minister's position nine more
since sue gray's report of those two
don't think he should go yet eight are
on the fence 27 are publicly calling for
the prime minister to go now and they
range from grandes like the former
brexit secretary david davis 2019 red
wall intake mps like alicia kearns and
those fighting slim majorities with the
lib dems in the south like steve hammond
a couple of mps i've spoken to have
suggested that they want to wait till
after the queen's platinum jubilee
before deciding if they want the prime
minister to go that could bring the
total ever closer to the 54 letters
needed to trigger a vote of no
confidence but of course it's impossible
to know exactly how many letters are
already in and we know that when theresa
may was prime minister only half of
those letters were declared when a vote
of no confidence was called
there's also the question of what went
on in lockdown in the prime minister's
private flat we understand messages sent
by carrie johnson could be revealed by
the privileges committee allegations of
another gathering on the day of boris
johnson's birthday but ministers are
resisting more partygate probes
my instinctive reaction is that there
have been two incredibly thorough
investigations that have gone on um and
unless there's something really striking
that hasn't been known about previously
then then i think they have been looked
into really thoroughly and and the
report was incredibly thorough
but next month in tibetan in devon lib
dems could overturn a 24 000 tory
majority same night labour hoped to take
back red wall wakefield two bar
elections that will test opinion beyond
westminster
but it is here where mps will decide why
the great political survivor boris
johnson could come undone ali fortescue
sky news